[Music]
before we start I like to know you a
little bit and to warm up this
presentation so let's let's do some some
knowing each other at least soon on the
technical stack how many of you are are
like doing docker and containers and I
want to see hands I would like to to
hear one clap just to have an audible
signal of the audience so docker alright
kubernetes less spark spark on
kubernetes alright great thank you very
much
awesome so today I'm going to talk to
you about how to transform kubernetes
how to make it and shape it to your own
purposes and for that I'm I am using the
the topic that we are doing at the
Proctor we're doing on transforming
kubernetes into this platform that
allows us to run a stream in a workload
and everything starts with this this
container that that revolution of being
able to pack your application and run it
anywhere I guess that was the tagline of
Java that so many years ago to have
built once and run everywhere now I
think with docker are we we are a bit
closer but then you need to start once
once you start doing this a lot you need
to get grips of how this this happens
and kubernetes is giving us a level of a
management on top of those deployments
but there are moments where we feel we
need more we need more capabilities we
need better ways to automate the things
the applications that we are deploying
we need better ways of gathering
resources to build up the stack that we
need to run our business and in today's
presentation I want to share with you a
pattern I think it's that's what it is
pattern of the operator
and how you can apply it to harness the
power of different components that are
available out there on kubernetes on the
open source space to create the
coordination and automation and
kubernetes that you require to deploy
your own application I'm Gerard masse I
work for like been mentioned before we
are the company behind Scala I
personally have been involved in the
scale community and in particular in
this part community since many years and
I've also been a participant on
Cassandra for a while those are my
coordinates if you want to reach me and
I'm also the author of a stream
processing with apache spark together
with my co-author a Francois Carrillo
it's out there since June so if you want
to know about the stream capabilities of
Apache spark and the two LPs then that's
a book you should get ok end of the ad
like bent so you probably know us for
Scala for akka for play those open
source frameworks out there we also work
on data systems and we have been
promoting the fast data architecture for
a few years now has been evolving into
this comprehensive chart where we are
supporting a number of runtimes
streaming engines and on top number of
providers on Prem and on cloud in
particular I'm working on on that top
layer there that's called like the EM
pipelines or pro-change that name
because everything is a pipeline these
days but what we're doing there is
coordinating actually the deployment and
runtime of those applications and some
of the lessons learned on building on
building that component is what I'm
going to share with you today so we were
talking about containers and containers
gave us three very important things a
way of a packaging and application is
completely self-contained you can take
it and run somewhere else without
worrying about dependencies other than
other systems we have an immutable
deployment one
you created your container that
container doesn't change anymore there
are ways to hack that of course but if
you are playing by the rules that
container will restart every time from a
known state and one rule that you should
live by is a single responsibility
principle where each container on is
only running one process one intended
use for it when we start using those
then we see this is very practical I can
run my HTTP front-end I can scale up my
gtp front-end I can scale up some of my
micro services I can deploy more micro
services and at some point in time to
start creating chaos so that that
previous scale that you had to deploy
and relaunch VMs and services and
whatever is now turning into their
different chaos on how to manage those
docker containers and make sense of all
the deployments most of them are manual
or don't by some scripting guru in your
organization then everybody knows when
he or she goes on holiday and there is
kubernetes and not the first one of
those cluster managers out there so we
had gern and we had missiles but
probably what unit is doing right is
that it comes with a set of services
already out of the box so you don't have
to worry about for example marathon and
on missiles to start deploying something
there are built-in APs and kubernetes
once you give them an image and some
descriptor file it will know how to run
this into a cluster that is enabled with
kubernetes
and more important than that is that
cloud providers are adopting kubernetes
as a standard mesh to deploy
applications so if you're running
kubernetes on a mini coop on your laptop
and you deploy develop something is
running there you can take it to GK you
can take it to Amazon you can take it to
Asher and you know that it will run
eventually with some tweaks here and
there okay so now that we have this
great platform let's say a space where
we can develop our applications we start
deploying things
and we see that our deployments they
start growing again a great tool give us
some means to do more and with that
additional power we start again
developing and deploying applications
and at some point we will want more the
kubernetes is great for scaling things
that are stateless whereas having a
stateful applications things that
require storage strings are required
checkpoints like databases like a
streaming systems are that harder to
achieve and like the basic construction
blocks that you have deployment a
stateful set and a pod might not be
sufficient to have your applications
your full application deployed for
example what happens if your where do
all doing streaming in this track today
and we have been hearing about Kafka
many times you you need to have a couple
of Kafka topics those cut Kafka topics
are running on a broker broker might not
be running there how do you create it it
will be will it be part of your
deployment if it's not then you're
breaking your pattern and you will need
something additional or something on the
side to deploy your application in fully
that's the role of the operator operator
is there to extend kubernetes to things
that they didn't understand before
things that they didn't know before
so kubernetes knows about services not
about pods not about a endpoint and port
but it might not know about
Kafka topic so what do we do if we want
to add that concept of a Kafka topic in
kubernetes a Kefka topic will need a
broker will need some storage and in
addition to that it will need to be
deployed on more than one broker because
we want a replication with one
partitioning it's not a really trivial
thing to do same thing with databases
what happens with databases for
replication how do you run a distributed
database on - like Cassandra on a system
like kubernetes so the operator pattern
was actually coined by Korres
it's a way of extending of actually
using the kubernetes api to tell
kubernetes there is there is an
extension point now there is some new
application that here or a new
capability that we want to add on
kubernetes and it becomes native to it
so like you can do get parts then the
next thing you can do is get and my own
resource it's it's a way of actually
encoding the knowledge that you have in
your organization to deploy applications
and that's very powerful because instead
of relying on humans around us humans
might get sick my move on might want to
do some other stuff you can encode that
knowledge into an operator and have a
reproducible deployment of your
application time and time again not only
that but the operator is also able to
listen to observe environment and the
things related in the events related to
your application and evaluate those for
example what happens if one of my topics
is not available anymore what happens if
one of my pots went down well there are
levels there for example if I have a
deployment maybe that pot belongs to
deployments or the deployment will take
care of it but my operator might take
care of the deployment and that that
sort of a let's call it recursive
responsibility makes it a very reusable
pattern but we have that observe things
that happen in my cluster in my
environment I get events I once I have
event I evaluate the event but what do I
need to do with this oh there is a pot
that went down I need to act and maybe I
need to launch a new pot I need to
migrate some component etc oh it's not
done well there are few components so
here is back providing definition of the
operator there are two things with an
operator there is a controller and there
is a description of the resource that is
offering and that that that system gets
then implemented in some software and
some structure some schema that gets
deployed into kubernetes the function
the function of a an operator can be
reduced to an streaming application so
that observe evaluate act loop can be
then implemented using a streaming
processor for example that is listening
to events that is processing those
events and generating some actions but
both sides are talking to the kubernetes
api and you get your input to decide
what to do you produce an action on
kubernetes that will change the
environment and you will receive
potentially some more events this is an
example of one of our own
implementations you see it's kind of
breathable in the extremes DSL we are
watching this pipelines application
custom resource or all the events
related to that we are also sending
those events to an parallel event called
the event flow and I am going to log
some of the events that are happening
there I am going to track some metrics
so I am injecting there the capability
to have some visibility some monitoring
and eventually the most important part
is that we are going to transform or to
act on that event and transform into an
action and once we have those actions we
can execute the actions send them back
to to kubernetes now there are many ApS
already like SDKs out there in the
golang community there are like three or
four different operator frameworks that
you can use to bootstrap the deployment
so the development of your of your
operators you don't have to like code
yourself the event listening and the
Watchers you use code like the core of
your application we are doing this in a
Scala we use what is
can can recall the name maybe I recall
it later some API to talk to kubernetes
implementation a scrubber let's
cooperate implementation to talk to
kubernetes from Scala operators so you
don't have to deploy everything or
develop everything yourself
there are many operators already
available out there so you can just take
them from the open source and deploy
them on your cluster to augment it with
capabilities like a database like
Cassandra a workflow system like airflow
in order database like elasticsearch run
a batch or streaming computations on
spark you can deploy brokers and topics
using the caf-co operator they are more
than one out there there is more than
one out there and so on and so on there
is a comprehensive list on the link
provided there
there are many many more and we are just
moving the goal a little bit now we have
operators I can do stuff for us how do
we take advantage of the new
functionality before before I go there I
would like to give you a bit more
insights on how the operator works so
there are two sides to one operator when
is the custom resource definition is a
schema that defines or describes the new
resource that you are adding and once
you have added that custom resource
definition to kubernetes then you can
talk directly to that custom resource
using instances like you had classes and
objects you have done the custom
resources where you say I want this or I
want that from you custom resource and
let's see how that works in a small
example this was previously a live
demonstration but now is migrated to to
the P shell that's a presentation shell
where everything is pasted it in into
this into these slides well I hope you
get the gist of it so we can do get your
these two using cube CTL and the series
will list the installed series on my
communities cluster that I am connected
to this is one of our test class
there's what do I see here I see that my
cluster has a number of CR DS already
deployed or installed we have flink
support installed there we have the
Kafka operator and a stream scene that
comes with number of different facets so
there we have a calf connect and the
Kafka bridge and for us of most
importance is the Kafka topics operator
so that we can create new topics and
manage those topics once they are
deployed we have that pipelines
application that were custom operator I
will be talking about it a bit later
during this presentation and the SPARC
operator also it comes with two sides
one that is dedicated for batch
processing that they scheduled the SPARC
applications where you can say please
run this at some moment and the SPARC
applications where you can say okay run
this and we are using it to run a
streaming workloads let's have a look at
one of them how does it look like so
here we have the Kafka topics list from
a stream see and we can request there
its description so please let let's get
that CRD described in Djamel and it's
very long channel because it's
specifying validation rules is
specifying how you call that a resource
and so specified how their instances of
that resource are called important very
important for us is this named stanza
it's telling us oh we can call this
resource using a standard cube CTL of
alright so let's let's do it let's say
keep the deal gave get Kafka topics that
was something that kubernetes didn't
know before once we install that CRE
that new capability is available in
tuber natives we can get it like any
other resource in kubernetes and there
we go I have a number of applications
deployed and there I have a list of
topics that are deployed in my cluster
there is this other side of the
description this side of the description
the spec it says how you need to
declare a instance of that resource so
that the resource or the controller for
that operator can understand it and what
he's saying here is that I need to have
a specific ation with partitions and a
specification with replicas and there is
a little bit more after that I just you
don't want to overcrowd this and it is
very similar to what we would do using
the Kafka API I would say I need a topic
I need so much replication and it's much
partitioning and Kafka will connect to
the broker and create it for you
so let's try to do that here I have a
definition using the jumble file for a
user topic and what he's saying is well
I specified there some metadata to
specify the name space where I'm
deploying this but then I have the topic
name the number of partitions and the
number of replicas also with additional
configuration for the retention time and
segment size whatever that is
I apply this again like any other
resource you see here the pattern now I
am talking into core native native
interactions covered it is native API
with I don't need to learn about the caf
KPI anymore I just need to know about
the specifics of this Jamo file I
created my usual topic and now if I list
it it's there so I have now a spark user
topic it has a three partitions and two
replicas what is striking and I hope I
can bring that message to you is that to
do this I don't need to install the calf
KPI on my machine I don't need to have
the binary so for the create topic I
don't need to write a program that says
connect to the broker with this
configuration and create this topic
programmatically no I did it
declaratively I just have a small Jamal
file that says this is a topic name I
need this is the partition this is the
replication and I give it to communities
and communities give me back a resource
like gives you back deployments like it
gives you back a pot and keeps giving a
good friend and it's augmenting the
capabilities that you have at your hand
to
create applications because now you have
a new trick under your sleeve you can
create an application at the streaming
and when you deploy that application you
deploy the logic and you deploy all the
needed resources to run it so now we
have a Kafka topic resource I showed you
we also have link operator deploy there
I have this park operator deployed there
the next question is oh they are doing
great things for us but how do i harness
that power how I can put it put it
together so that I can create an
application that is comprehensive that
can take pieces I can put together
actually like Lego blocks put together
pieces of every one of those providers
providers of services and create
something a solve a business problem for
me and that's what I called operator
Federation that's the idea come today to
present to you here I start with one
example and this I'll be liked about it
it's how the spike operator works there
is a controller there the controller
understands this jamel file and the Yama
file for SPARC is a little bit more
complex and the one with you so but it's
saying this is the docker image that we
have these are the different
configurations that I need etcetera etc
the operator controller would do a
submission to spark and a spark will
deploy this into kubernetes the
interesting part there when you start
looking under the hood of how these
things are working
is that a spark itself also implements a
operator pattern inside spark to be able
to deploy those executors on kubernetes
so it's also going to go to kubernetes
and say I need pods
to run this executor and I need so many
because these DISA specification say I
need to replicate for example 220 cores
so I might need 10 executors with two
cores each that kind of negotiation is
done by a spark and not by the SPARC
operator so oh so there is already some
cascading effect there the operator says
I need this application
and spud says and it is component
running also the the monitoring and how
do you react to events is then having a
cascade effect or having kind of
contained bubble of responsibility in
the spark driver that is a part of the
spark application will will be taking
care of monitoring the executors if one
executors goes down you will receive an
event it will spawn a new executor it
will say here are your binaries please
execute this task so it will become part
of that spark cluster again the operator
doesn't need to know about it from time
to time you will say give me your health
and I want to know how are you doing in
terms of run time and in terms of the
number of executors you have but that's
that's about it we have a nice fair of
responsibility and we don't need to take
care of that
which allow us to increase the level of
abstraction so now we have a spark
operator
I give you my application and you take
care of deploying it it gives it to
spark and it takes care of keeping it
running very interesting but if I want
to stream an application then I also
need my Kafka topics or maybe some entry
points maybe some HTTP endpoints that I
want to deploy to get to gather data
from the outside and what I would like
is to have something that knows my
application that has some insight on my
application and is able to deploy all
those components and infer that I need
those and keep them running
so does that custom operator there will
be getting event of what is happening
with the SPARC operator is my spark
application still running has it go down
if it went down please restart it but I
can also execute actions to it I can
also scale it up or change it and
configure it and how we use indecent in
let's say in real life we have developed
a system that actually harness together
your development environment using SBT
they're not really simple built to
with with some additional components are
some plugins we we are able to compose
the application and say this is this is
how an application looks like and there
might be a built of different backends
you can say I want on my front-end done
we are doing it with Akash TTP inaka
streams so I want to deploy large front
end to have some HTTP endpoints where I
can gather data from my T devices or
whatever out there and then I want to
process the data using flame chorus in a
spark and I want to produce it use to a
database or to some other system then I
can use all my alpaca connectors from
open source I can plug them there and
use them to produce data downstream to
show you how that works
I'm going to introduce a simplified use
case this is inspired by real life one
of our customers creates created this
application actually by hand at the
beginning to process called data records
so this is a telecommunications operator
they have data coming from the fields
actually from the master the antennas
out there reporting the community
connection connectivity of cell phones
and they do some aggregation on top of
that data that is produced on to kafka
and to some HDFS back-end so that flow
internally there goes through several
extreme processor and they all the
aggregation is the inner spark spark
using the streaming framework to produce
the aggregate aggregations that go to to
HDFS and to cassandra eventually we
abstract this concept and saying alright
first first of all everything the
communication between the things is
driven by schemas this is very important
because it tells us what is the data and
what is shape of the data is that is
going between components you can
validate it you can know my my
application end to end is consistent and
it's consistent with the data and
providing to it you can also filter this
start of your application start of your
pipeline and say this is data that I
don't recognize so it's not entering the
rest of the application not having a
chance for corrupting a any subsequent
subsequent element there this concept of
streamlets is a component you could
compare it to a small application that
contains the business logic written in
the back end of your choice you might be
using flink ya might be using a spark
you might be using extremes we don't
kind of build on tougher api is really
clean the api of the provider and what
we are doing is providing a way to build
this to package this into docker docker
containers and link them together and
deploy it now I am back on my my magical
shell here it's amazing it takes forever
it doesn't it even to run because you
can edit it so this is my this is my
project and that project that implements
this use case has a number of components
implemented that sub project so I have
an injector there that takes the data I
have an aggregation output that is put
in the data somewhere else is producing
it to the downstream systems and I have
a data model declaring all the data that
is being shared between the within the
components and the spark a Greg a tion
that is contained in that business logic
to aggregate those Colin records next to
that I have this concept of blueprint
and I think that's the name that came in
the previous presentation so all these
concepts and somehow linked but the
blueprint is saying this is how those
components are linked together that also
this is the relationship a direct
acyclic graph defining how the data
flows from one component to the next so
I'm saying here that the generator one
out goes to a merge so there are two
generators going into a merge there is
an ingress that goes to the merge and
then the output of that mer
gets validated and whatever that valid
goes to the aggregation and whatever
it's invalid goes to an error or a dead
letter q then using this extension of
the built I can build and publish build
and publish to us two things at the same
time first it builds your whole project
all the all the binaries of the projects
compilation face normal compilation
phase and at the end of it it generates
a docker file and the docker file
contains the binaries for every single
component in your application but also
information about this blueprint now
transform into what you could call a
deployment plan this is what I need to
do to transform those little
applications little components services
into a comprehensive end-to-end system
now I can go and deploy this to a cover
needs cluster that has my operator
deployed there and then the deployment
start Here I am running on OpenShift and
on Prime understandable more or less but
but usually we consider is that now I
have an application has been created
there are a number of pots being
launched there and after a minute or two
all the pots are active and running so I
have deployed in application that is
composed of three four different stages
like an atomic action and that atomic
action is actually being taken care of
by the operator itself relying and
delegating responsibilities to the
different orders of operators correct
call them to realize the independent
functions I need topics so the topics
have been created I need to launch merge
the HTTP services I need to have a need
to be ingress for each one of them so
those are obtained from kubernetes now I
need to launch a spark
when I launched a spark I also have some
executors that are there and you can
extend this concept and say I now and we
want to have a constable scaling up but
is this it means very different things
for therefore different frameworks you
want to scale Cassandra you need to do
something different if you want to scale
Kafka our spark and but scale for your
end-user becomes an abstract concept but
I can say I just want more capacity and
I said there am i a Grenadier needs to
grow from whatever it is now to five so
I do this earlier aggregate to five so
the previous one is terminated the new
one is launched and then then the new
five executors are launched you see here
that the way of deploying this was to
remove the previous one and deploy the
new one let's a spark if we were
deploying extremes we'll just increasing
the deployment and so we will have liked
if we were previously three we will have
like two more and that's it then but
what is then let's say the next trick is
that as the operator is coordinating all
these different actions it also can
inject some of its own logic on every
deployment and we are using that to
inject the primitives rules for
exporting metrics from every one of such
components giving us the capability to
first have a complete view of the
topology that that's what the the chart
you are seeing there that's how the
application looks as a full deployment
and on the other pain you see the
performance of one of the components now
that I have clicked there so this is the
input and outputs throughput of that
particular component so in a nutshell
what we have done is taking that concept
of the operator and have extended it
through a model of Federation now we we
create our own operator that is in
charge of
handling work to other operators we have
few design principles in this
application land is this blueprint it
tells you or gives you a map of how
things are connected together very
important because you cannot infer that
from any Arab element their schema
driven keeps you sane because you know
what the data in with the data out is
from each one of the elements and it
also increases the ability for you to
reuse any component you know what the
data they are required you know what the
data they produce and they can be
composed with each other we have been
using and extending the build tool to do
things for us so we don't have to write
Gamal or the developer doesn't have to
write Gamal it's how to generate it for
you because from the blueprint and all
the code that you have written with some
introspection we know what you want to
achieve this on the deployment side
there is a CLI what you saw in the cube
CTL is a plug-in there a CLI that allows
you to interact with with kubernetes and
the operator clue of this today's
presentation is that put all those
pieces together this is code that you
write this is knowledge that you
transfer from your sweat in your tears
and your brain into some code and you
have it end and running and working for
you 24/7 all right so that's a thought
that I leave to you we use these two in
to implement the streaming workloads but
you can reuse the same system to do your
implementation for your travel trips
manager whatever whatever the business
you're in in health and travel insurance
you can find ways of how to reuse that
pattern to your benefits and I hope that
you do well there are some resources
there it operator the caf-co operator
we're using confluent also has one and
if you have questions I think I have
time for one for a wise you can
thank you for the talk so I was
wondering if because you said the system
is a schema driven I was wondering if it
supports the schema evolution as well
sorry if or if it supports changes in
this schema which is kheema so the whole
system you had like it's a schema driven
you validate yes yes of course yeah
there is there is a schema migration so
there are two ways of supporting that
compatible schema migrations is what we
recommend when you extend your schema to
add new fields those fields become
optional so that the existing state of
the system still works and you don't
need any migration if you really do a
breaking change in your schema schema is
completely incompatible then you will be
forced to introduce a component that
translate the previous scheme and to the
new schema I think that's what we are
doing at this moment thank you hi so you
said that in your controller you
delegate the creation of spark related
things to a spark basically so when you
deploy the controller you deployed with
an instance of spark running or is it
talk to other instances of spark
learning so they don't know if I can
find as quickly probably do so what
happens here the spark operator is it
also implements the same pattern it's
also a controller and it listens to
kubernetes events so you don't you don't
use spark command like expect submit but
you instead throw a channel to this
thing
Djamel that describes your application
and then the operator there will take
the channel and the specifications
within it to really create a spark
deployment and that's what's happening
behind the scenes so if you see here
where it's a bit broken up and I would
say the the controller what it says is
what it does is takes the Jamal
transform that jumbled into the submit
parameters there are subtil ities there
there are for example if you are using
streaming you also need a checkpoint
directory on a shared storage that share
storage is created before this what we
are also doing it from outside in the
controller here but that's what's
happening so every controller takes
responsibility well it's a hierarchical
organization takes responsibility for
what happens underneath from happens
with the things I did create and it
manages
[Music]